[Music]
hello how are you and ended with the
most outstanding headlines for today monday
november 16 a person is dead after
a shooting inside an apartment complex
near tropicana and but
the authorities responded
around 4 in the morning and found  one
adult dead at the scene the police
said a woman who had asked
her friend to walk her home
this man approached the woman and
her friend quickly went into the
apartment and closed the door the
man fired a gun  Once
the friend fired through the door and
that bullet killed the subject.
Two weeks have passed since
official election day, however, the county
court will have the official count of
ballots by this afternoon. The
registrar of voters will report to
the commission in  a special meeting
scheduled for one in the afternoon
resorts world will open next summer and is
already preparing to hire staff
from now on the resort will be  accepting
job applications anyone
interested should follow their
website for updates on open
positions and now we turn to
the weather forecast today we will have a
warm sunny day with a high
hovering around 86 degrees this week
we will see temperatures above
normal but  Don't get used to it because
the cold will return for the weekend.
Have a nice day. I am Sal y
Jaramillo and this was your brief
newsletter for the Spanish edition
[Music]